quedan solamente 48 horas para que
Turquía vote en esta segunda vuelta de
las elecciones la oposición Eso sí llega
anímicamente en sus horas más bajas por
el golpe de realidad ocurrido el pasado
14 de mayo recordemos que recepta y
perdogan sacó el
49,5% del apoyo popular Mientras que el
líder opositor que malcelelulu se quedó
con el 44,9 es justamente esta
diferencia de cinco puntos la Que los
separa ahora mismo según las encuestas
el perdón sacaría en torno al 52% del
apoyo popular mientras que quema el
kilíd se quedaría en torno al 47
48% de los votos el ala
ultranacionalista como hemos visto
durante esta última semana ha entrado en
escena
ha podido convencer a ese 5% de las
personas de los electores que votaron al
tercer candidato sinanoan este mismo
esta misma semana ha pedido el voto para
resetta y perdone por lo tanto ahora
mismo el actual presidente estaría cada
vez más cerca de revalidar la
presidencia